hey youtubers is Charlie so there's a
new trailer for arrow that aired only in
Australia I'll say spoiler warning it's
it's probably very misleading I'm gonna
play it now it is shite quality so I
just wanted to prompt you guys so here
we go
[Music]
because the quality of that solo I
couldn't find a higher quality ripp this
is what Felicity's mother says the
damage to her spinal cord is permanent
she's never going to walk again and then
it you know like all gaps and oh my god
in the last couple of DC videos I've
posted I referenced this Twitter post
from Marc Guggenheim the showrunner
where he's like Felicity's gonna have a
hallucination take that for what you
will now I don't know if this promo
dropped before he posted that on Twitter
so it can't be absolutely certain that
he's talking about this promo
specifically but I think they're almost
done filming episode 14 or they've
already started filming episode 15 and
she was seen in a wheelchair on set so I
think you know bare minimum she is gonna
be in a wheelchair for a while the real
question is is is she ever going to walk
again
is the trailer completely misleading us
already in the background I can hear all
you Walking Dead fans screaming bull
crap at the same time rewind the last
year what did they do for the mid-season
finale
they killed quote/unquote killed Oliver
Queen only they did not kill him he was
on the edge of death they brought him
right back in that next episode it was
still a really big deal it was all about
this big shift in the Oliver Queen
character this pivotal move in
neutralizing Rochelle Goyle getting rid
of the threat of the League of Assassins
so when it seems like the show is doing
with felicity is giving her this big
mountain to climb so to speak just like
Oliver climbed the mountain last season
only she has to overcome this great
disability she has to get to the point
where she can walk again and what is
this gonna do to her psychologically
that's another big thing - how is she
gonna process all this and how is she
going to go on it's gonna be her
crucible for the back half of the season
and I think that that's really good news
I think you guys will probably really
dig it because really what's going on
with her character right now she's
running Palmer tech mr. terrific scenes
are really the only Palmer tech stuff
that we've gotten every season there are
a couple different types of challenges
the characters have to overcome their
mental challenges like Oliver coming to
the conclusion that he needs to be the
green arrow he can't be the arrow any
more physical challenges is then I have
to defeat this other villain
or I have to overcome a physical
disability so it's not like Felicity's
gonna kill her disability but she will
get to face her father I think she's
gonna be in the wheelchair for several
episodes if not the entire rest of the
season but I don't think she's
officially going to become the Oracle
character I'm expecting a whole bunch of
Oracle Easter eggs but if DC and Warner
Brothers wouldn't let arrow use the
title Oracle for one of their episodes
of last season then unless they've
changed their minds unless they
completely reversed their position she's
not gonna be Oracle she'll just be
Felicity Smoak doing Oracle things and
if you really want to go deep you could
say she's kind of been an Oracle
character since the moment she debuted
way back in season 1 so unless one of
the producers comes forward and says
absolutely yes are absolutely no Oracle
you could go either way and you would be
correct I think the best way to think
about it now is that she is unofficially
Oracle but Gotham actually said that
it's hoping to do a Barbara Gordon's
storyline so I would think that they
would bookmark the character for that
show but but because I think their
version of Barbara Gordon is gonna be
Jim Gordon and Lee's child even if they
were allowed to use the name Oracle I
don't think they would ever get to it
because it always be like a little girl
first she has to be Batgirl then she
gets to be Oracle so let me know what
you guys think this is actually the real
question do you think this trailer is a
complete misdirect is this part of the
hallucination that Marc Guggenheim was
talking about and will Felicity ever
walk again it only sucks when you have
to gun someone down in the street as
proxy for character development but I am
excited for the direction that the
Felicity character is going to go expect
a very different type of Felicity for
the next couple of episodes arrow is the
show has gotten a little bit lighter
it's a little more jokey like the Oliver
Queen of the comics like the Green Arrow
comics but I don't think post-accident
Felicity will ever go back to being
exactly like she was before the accident
she'll be just a little more serious but
the good news is we're not gonna have to
wait that long to figure out what's
going on arrows back on the 20th
remember it's flash on the 19th then
arrows back that next time on the 20th
then legends of tomorrow episode 1 on
the 21st and I'll put a link for it in
the description but I talked a little
bit about the arrow flash crossover with
legends of tomorrow it's not gonna be
exactly like when arrow and flash
crossover with each other but that
actually reminds me new round of the
reverse flash ring giveaway starts now
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video and I am gonna do a new legends of
tomorrow
video they had some really cool stuff
about the show while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for my
flash video explaining what's going on
with the back half of season 2 will soon
Kevin Smith directing an episode a whole
bunch of stuff happening and you can
click here for that Batman do you bleed
teaser from last night thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight